sind tintenfische nicht von dieser welt
bei dieser kassen meldung kommt man
darüber ins grübeln es klingt verrückt
aber die aliens der meere können
tatsächlich ihr eigenes erbgut verändern
diese entdeckung war ich von allem ab
was wir sonst aus der tierwelt kennen
und macht die hoch intelligenten
weichtiere noch spannender wenn kranken
und karl mahrer durchdenken erbgut
verändern können was bedeutet das dann
für die zukunft der genforschung kriegs
um science fiction die gibt's täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's sich
willkommen pixum gibt es übrigens auch
als podcast zum hören die links spotify
und apple podcast sind unten in der
video beschreibung unbedingt mal
anklicken im ozean gibt es echte genies
unter den weichtieren und sie sind
anders als alles was wir an land kennen
kraken und kalmare sind einen komplett
anderen evolution weg gegangen als wir
und haben extrem komplexe gehirne
ausgebildet die hoch intelligenten tiere
können sich verdammt gut an ihre
umgebung anpassen und jagen selbst
menschen im rudel wie die humboldt
kalmare doch nicht nur ihre hirne sind
speziell ein amerikanisches
forschungsteam vom original center in
woods hole hat jetzt eine krasse
entdeckung bei den tintenfischen gemacht
bei einer untersuchung an den
nervenzellen des nordamerikanischen
khammas stellten sie fest dass die tiere
beim denken sogar ihr erbgut verändern
können das klingt unglaublich weil
menschen und den meisten tierarten
bleiben die gene in der regel
unverändert bis sie re kombiniert und
dadurch an die nächste generation
weitergegeben werden das gilt auch für
die messenger erna kurz mrsa die dient
dazu dass moleküle im zellkern die dna
auslesen und sie aussenden können um so
der restlichen zelle zu sagen welche
proteine sie für den zellaufbau braucht
bisher ging man davon aus dass eine
veränderung dieser boten-rna außerhalb
des zellkerns kaum oder gar nicht
möglich ist doch die neuen ergebnisse
ändern alles denn die tintenfische sind
genau dazu in der lage kranken und
kalmare können die erbinformation ihrer
neuronen beim transport umschreiben so
dass ihr nervensystem eine viel größere
vielfalt an protein nennt
das wäre quasi so als würde eine datei
nachdem sie von einem programm
geschrieben wurde
auf dem weg zum empfänger geändert
werden würde das programm wirft zum
beispiel einen bauplan für einen
schlafzimmerschrank aus aber beim
empfänger kommt ein veränderte bauplan
für eine kommode an und die baut er dann
auch das programm ist dabei die dna und
dna ist der bauplan vollkommen anders
als gene ansonsten in lebewesen
funktionieren dadurch haben die gene je
nach ihrem ort in der zelle eine andere
basenabfolge die forschenden fanden in
den aktionen der nervenzellen zwei
enzyme die die basenabfolge der
messenger rna verändern diese rna
transportiert die informationen dann aus
den genen zu den proteinfabriken der
zelle die enzyme in den enden dieser
nervenfortsätze haben also nicht nur
einen anderen aufbau als in der den dna
des zellkerns vorgegeben war sie haben
auch eine andere struktur als im rest
der zelle dieser krasse unterschied zum
rest der tierwelt könnte auch aufschluss
über weitere besonderheiten ihres
nervensystems geben nervenzellen von
tintenfischen haben extreme lange axone
das ding die fortsätze die nerven
impulse vom zellkörper weg leiten
in diesen aktionen hat man die
erbgutveränderungen entdeckt man fand
darin die enzyme a 1 und a 2 die in der
mma die basa adenin in dosen umwandeln
diese endet dem guanin und so wird im
genetischen code der buchstabe a in g
umgewandelt solche änderungen finden
normalerweise ausschließlich im zellkern
statt und sind dann für die gesamte
zelle gültig dazu kommt noch dass die
msa in den tintenfisch nerven fast 1000
mal so oft umgeschrieben wird wie bei
allen anderen tieren schon vor ein paar
jahren hatten forschende festgestellt
dass denke meine kammer im laufe seines
lebens mehr als 68 prozent der rna
seines nervensystems eigenständig
verändert dadurch optimiert er
vermutlich seine hirn physiologie um
sich besser an die
temperaturunterschiede im ozean
anzupassen
man fand heraus dass kraken ihre gene
für aktionen proteinen nachträglich
ändern aber man wusste noch nicht dass
das direkt dort passiert warum die tiere
das machen ist bislang noch unklar
könnte aber erklären warum sie so
außergewöhnlich intelligent sind auf
jeden fall können sie durch viele
regierungen jede menge physiologische
prozesse
steuern die forschungsgruppe schreibt in
ihrer studie die vorstellung dass
genetische informationen auf ganz
unterschiedliche weise als bislang
bekannt innerhalb der zelle
umgeschrieben werden kann ist ein ganz
neuer verständnis ansatz und erweitert
unsere vorstellung davon wie ein
einzelner bauplan genetischer
informationen zur räumlicher komplexität
führen kann
die entdeckung kann jetzt also völlig
neue ansätze für die gentechnik eröffnen
durch solche nachträglichen rna
veränderungen können gene genau so
umgeschrieben werden wie durch eine
veränderung der dna sequenz nur dass
solche veränderungen nicht vererbt
werden und auch keine bleibenden schäden
verursachen so eine indizierung wären
tatsächlich sicherer als verfahren wie
die gegen shell küster die durch
dauerhafte veränderung schäden im erbgut
verursachen kann
die weitervererbt werden außerdem
eröffnet sie völlig neue möglichkeiten
da sie nicht mal durch das
gentechnikrecht eingeschränkt werden
würde astrobiologie tintenfische kommen
aus dem all anklicken anschauen und
abonnieren und zwar klicks um
science-fiction falls ihr es noch nicht
getan haben solltet also bis dann bleibt
dran